and today's theme is algorithms and
shallow circuits so I guess we're going
to start out with the shallow circuits
part of the theme with a talk with
Daniel by Daniel Greer and we will
continue with
umesh's game plan of discussion trumping
schedule so keep that in mind so
um but it's great to have Daniel here uh
giving us a talk on Quantum Advantage
with shallow Clifford circuits
okay uh awesome thanks for the
introduction and thanks for everyone for
coming to the sort of morning session
I'm very excited to be here at Simon's
and nice to chat with a lot of you so
yeah so the title of this talk is sort
of quantum Advantage with shallow
Clifford circuits and I was sort of
asked to give a talk on sort of like the
complexity of of shallow circuits and I
didn't really have sort of a result that
was sort of like hot off the press to
tell you guys so I thought instead what
I would do
so what I'm giving you is sort of like
an overview of sort of uh you know this
is this kind of sub feel that sort of as
sort of through my eyes and then sort of
end with some sort of open questions and
things that I think um I would like to
be solved and you know possible
Direction so maybe this is like a sort
of like a budget version of the talk you
saw by Scott Aronson yesterday
um so
uh let me start with sort of what is
going to be sort of like you know
probably totally uncontroversial uh uh
definition of quantum Advantage so what
does this even mean so you know we say
we you know we have achieved a Quantum
Advantage if there's a problem that can
be solved with a quantum computer
that cannot be solved by sort of a
comparable uh class of the computer at
least then there's some like some
assumptions
so uh so yeah I think you know sort of
the first thing that we have to sort of
like you know wrap our minds around is
like what do we even mean by sort of a
problem
so uh at the very least I'm gonna uh you
know specify that it must have some uh
classical inputs and classical outputs
and you know we're kind we're comparing
what the quantum computer is doing to
what the classical computer is doing so
in the classical computer at least has
to be able to sort of like play the game
but we'll see later there's sort of many
different ways in which we could
instantiate this kind of problem and
then just to sort of like remind you you
know we've become sort of like very
Adept at this in the field now right
like you know the problem that we sort
of come up with here doesn't doesn't
have to be useful at all so just some
arbitrary thing that we come up that's
just sort of difficult for the quantum
computer to simulate or for the class
computer simulator
um and then you know there's some also
some like nice to haves here so with
with kind of Advantage you could sort of
say it's like you know maybe it's
implementable in the near term uh maybe
you want sort of verifiability and maybe
you even want to do all of this with uh
no conjectures you know just completely
just like you know I don't need to rely
on complexity Theory I don't need to
rely on random Matrix Theory I just sort
of you know has the results
okay so this seems like sort of
impossible and yet I'm going to claim to
you that uh sort of the sort of results
that I'm going to tell you about today
sort of satisfy all of these things so
you know uh you know Scott would be sort
of very very happy
um okay but of course you know I I've
cheated in some in some way so so where
did I where did I cheat right so I
I I cheat I cheated in this word
comparable right so the the circuits
that I'm going to be talking about today
the quantum circus that we're going to
be talking about are extremely weak
um right so shallow Clifford circuits
and so in some sense it makes sense to
compare them to classical circuits which
are weak in a similar sense so we're
going to be taking these shallow
Clifford circuits they're going to be
solving problems and we're going to be
showing that they solve problems
uh which their sort of comparable
classical classes cannot solve and it
will sort of satisfy all of these
conditions
okay so uh you know just so that you
know to to be safe so we're all on the
same page here right so what is a
Clifford circuit so it's just a a
Quantum circuit that consists of
hadamard phase uh and control Trona
Gates like this so you know here's
here's the circuit this one has sort of
uh four layers to it and we'll say that
it's shallow uh if it has constant depth
so just constantly many layers of gates
and one thing that I think uh maybe is
worth sort of pointing out now
um is I I sort of May sometimes sort of
use the clipboard circuit when what I
actually mean is a classically
controlled Clifford circuit so uh you
know we're going to be sort of uh
defining sort of computational problems
uh it might make sense in a
computational problem to say I want you
to sort of prepare some Clifford State
and then measure its output and sort of
tell me some property of its output
but how do we actually determine uh
which Clifford circuit we're going to
run or there's going to be some
classical input which is going to
describe which Gates we're going to run
so even though it may look here that
like I've you know sort of put like a
toefully gate in my circuit I'm only
ever going to run these sort of these
top wires here with classical inputs so
what remains is always just going to be
a Clifford circuit and so that's I'm
just going to kind of use them
interchangeably from here and out this
sort of for Simplicity
okay
uh so so here's one world a view of the
world that you might have so uh you know
I want to talk about sort of the
complexity of simulating a Clifford
circuit so Clifford circuits is just a
subset of you know General Quantum
circuits so obviously sort of the class
of problems that you could solve with
liver circuits is you know smaller than
the class of problems or at least
contain the class of problems that you
can solve with is there a general
purpose quantum computer
but many of you will have this review of
the world well you actually know that in
Clifford circuits and at least in terms
of computation are classically tractable
right so I can solve them and sort of
polynomial time
and you know for many of you this might
be your sort of like complete view of
the world right like you know you just
you view these Clifford circuits these
are like very weak things like you know
they're useful for certain subroutines
and Quantum computation so on and so
forth but for the most part like in
terms of computation they're just like
these extremely weak uh devices
but I want to sort of like challenge
that notion now so like what if we look
down here right so there's there's more
to the to the story right and so if we
look down here uh we can see that
there's like sort of like a whole sort
of like Kingdom of classes and you know
the Cliffords are doing pretty well
right they're sort of up here at the top
right so the sort of uh first thing that
you uh may see is that I've written uh
Clifford is equal to parity l so this
was a result of
where they showed that at least in terms
of for the purposes of computation
the the hatter Martin the phase Gates
really aren't doing much for you right
you can just sort of replace them all
with the you know just simulate your
circuit using so you knock Agents from
the purposes of doing some computation
that's good enough
okay and there's all these other classes
here which I'm not going to Define uh
right now but we'll be sort of defined
slowly throughout the talk but if
there's something that you're sort of
particularly curious about right now I
can can certainly ask that but sort of
the question the sort of that I want to
sort of think about for this talk is
where do these shallow Clipper circuits
belong right so so clearly you know they
belong to the Clifford circuits because
they're just the constant depth version
of the Clifford circuits but is there
some sense in which shallow Clifford
circuits also enjoy all of the
advantages that these sort of general
purpose Clippers have so you know are
they more powerful than these classes
say
the question we're trying to solve
um and you know the the the answer may
surprise you okay
um so I can't really go on any further
without talking about the sort of
specific kinds of uh problems that we're
talking about so
something uh which we're sort of
probably all sort of a little bit more
comfortable with now that the after
yesterday's session is sampling problems
so I'm sort of this is not sort of like
the most def like general definition of
a sampling problem that you could have
but it's sort of the a definition which
is going to be sort of good enough for
us so I'm always going to Define these
types of problems sort of in terms of
the quantum circuit which is doing a
task and then sort of the classical uh
task is just kind of to do whatever the
quantum circuit is doing so in this
sampling task you're given some input X
which is something you know bitstring
and that you know determines what some
Quantum circuit is so maybe the bit
string is telling you which gates to
apply on which wires
and then your sort of goal in the
sampling task is sort of you take that
circuit that you got from that input
apply it to say the all zero State and
measure and then output a bit string
which is in uh which is sampled from
that distribution that the quantum
circuit was sampling from
so that's what a sampling problem is and
you know there's a a a lot of different
ways in which you can sort of like
contort this problem for various needs
you know you could say why maybe I only
want to Output a y which is uh from a
distribution which is like close and
total variation distance and all these
things that we get into with random
circuit sampling that I'm not going to
get into with this task or with this
with this talk
now because I'm going to move to a
simpler setting which is uh the a
relational setting so here we have sort
of the same kind of idea we have a bit
string X and it's going to determine
some Quantum circuit Q
and once again you apply the quantum
circuit q and you measure but now your
goal is you only need to Output some bit
string which is in the support of the
distribution
so this is like a completely uh sort of
like you know a stupid notion for like
General RCS right because what you do
you just output any bit string it's
going to be in support maybe it has an
exponentially tiny probability but it's
still going to be there
but for Clifford circus this will not be
true right so for Clifford circuits many
of many of the bit strings are not going
to be in support they have probability
or amplitude zero and so we can't just
do that right we have we have to we have
to have some kind of knowledge about the
structure of what the the quantum
circuit is doing
okay so these are the kinds of problems
that for the most part we're going to be
thinking about these relation problems
okay so I sort of like uh sort of done
all the setups so now it's sort of like
the first uh result you know dare I say
a breakthrough in this area
and what they showed was that these
constant depth Clifford circuits can
solve a relation problem that can be
solved by sort of uh that cannot be
solved by these bounded fan in constant
depth circuits with and or not Gates so
okay so sort of pictorially we have this
sort of Separation here where we have
the sort of classical circuit on the
left in this sort of quantum shallow
Clifford circuit on the right
and so we just kind of like stare at
these we can see that they're sort of
like kind of similar right so both of
these have a constant depth and both of
them are using Gates that have bounded
fan in
uh and yeah you can show that the
relation problem that is being solved by
this Clifford circuit
cannot be solved by this constant depth
circuit
and this is just full stop there no
there are no conjectures necessary
there's nothing this is just true
so this is kind of amazing and in some
sense you might think this is kind of
the end of the story right because this
seems like a a pretty fair comparison
right so in the in the sort of parlance
of complexity Theory we might say that
this is a relational separation between
the classical circuit class and z0 and
the quantum circuit class Cube nc0
all right so maybe this seems like this
is you know the end of the story but uh
you could you could hope for more right
you could say maybe I I I take the same
Quantum circuit the same simple Quantum
circuit but I show that sort of even
more powerful classes of classical
computation can't solve that relation
problem that the that the quantum
circuit is solving
okay and so can you can you do this well
okay probably yes so follow-up work by
Benny Watts guitar chaifer and tall
so it showed that you can sort of with
essentially the same task the same
relation problem
you can add unbounded fan and Gates
unbounded and or not gates to your to
your classical circuit class so you now
you get ac0 instead of nc0
and even these classical circuits still
cannot simulate this these like sort of
simple quantum
30 seconds
okay so we can just keep getting more
and more greedy right can we how far can
we push this how how you know how
powerful can we make this class such
that it's still not able to simulate
these things
so uh follow work by myself and Luke
Shafer uh we sure this is this is true
um okay modulo this this sort of like
interactive thing which I'm going to
spend a lot of time talking about uh
later there's a a relation problem that
can be solved by an unbounded fan in uh
sorry that can that can be solved by
these style Eclipse circuits that can't
be solved by these unbounded consistent
circuits with the addition of parity
Gates so now we've sort of added yet
another gate to our circuit class and
shown that it still cannot simulate
these are quantum circuits so if you
haven't worked in uh you know a shallow
depth lower bounds before or something
you know this may seem like very
unimpressive right like I'm just adding
these like tiny Gates each time like you
know what's the big deal so let me sort
of like try to put these sort of these
results sort of like in context for you
here so
so we started with a a problem which can
be solved by a constant of the Clifford
circuit that couldn't even be solved by
this uh constant depth classical circuit
and then we sort of like increased the
power of the classical circuit a bit
more we added these unbounded Fanning
Gates
so this past ac0 and yet and these
classes still couldn't solve this this
simple relation problem solved by the
constant depth Clifford circuit and then
we added parody Gates and yet it still
couldn't solve and so you know we could
sort of look at these and say like well
in each case we sort of knew that we
were sort of like strictly increasing
the power of the class because of some
results in complexity Theory all right
this one is kind of trivial but this one
is very non-trivial
so what if we wanted to sort of like
keep pushing this further and further
like what if I I got even more greedy
and I wanted to solve uh you can create
like even better lower bounds against
these classes
well the problem is that we don't really
know like sort of our techniques in
classical complexity Theory kind of like
bottom out here right so what we can
show instead
is that if we did have better
unconditional separations In classical
complexity then this would lead to
better unconditional separations between
these Quantum and classical computers
so in particular uh if I could show if I
could prove that nc1 is not equal to l
so log depth circuits are not equal to
log space Turing machines
at least in the non-uniform model then
this would imply through the result that
I showed on the previous page
that there's a relation an interactive
relation problem solved by these
constant Quantum circuits that can't be
solved by even a log depth classical
circuit so that's you know sort of uh
quite amazing and it sort of like only
depends on sort of a non-inclusion of
complexity classes like this is sort of
like uh you know the sort of I what I
view as sort of like the the perfect
kind of conjecture that you could have
right it would be amazing if we could
say we would have Quantum Supremacy only
if P would not equal the P space right
you know if we could make some
conjecture like that that would be
amazing okay so of course the conjecture
that we have are are much stronger than
that
yeah you can you can sort of change the
changes all around so I I'll get into
the result exactly later but what we
show is essentially that you can
leverage a classical simulation
of this protocol to solve anything in
paradiel and so any sort of two classes
which are below parity L and this
diagram that I showed earlier if those
two are separate then it separates
the task from whatever was below it and
then that separation
okay
so that that's sort of like uh
sort of the results and now let me sort
of just like kind of go through what
exactly I want to want to do here so how
do you actually go about proving a
Quantum Advantage with these yeah
things that you can solve with
polynomial death c not Gates
so uh in where so I'll show this again
later but we're kind of maxing out the
complexity in some sense like that's as
hard as the problem can be and and
we're showing that in some sense if you
if you have a classical Simulator for
this uh Quantum task then you can solve
that sort of maximally hard problem
um
you'll you'll see you'll see it again
later so hopefully if that didn't make
sense it'll make more sense later
um
okay so I want to sort of talk about
sort of the sort of two ideas here so
there's this non-interactive setting
this relation setting that we saw in the
beginning this gave us these separations
against nc0 and ac0
and I want to sort of claim that there's
the there's like one key classical
bottleneck which we're sort of
exploiting here which is that the
quantum circuit is is non-local but uh
nc0 and ac0 are are local in kind of a
strong sense and and that's why you
can't get around uh you're not really
using much about the computation which
is actually going on in the Clifford
circuit you're just sort of using the
fact that it has these sort of non-local
correlations and so we'll see how that
comes up
but in the in the interactive setting
where we get separations against ac02
and and possibly Beyond depending on
your belief in certain conjectures
um we'll show that the class of little
bottleneck is really the computation
itself that if you were to solve the
task
that you're sort of being presented with
you know solving this relation problem
then what you're really being asked to
do is you're being asked to do arbitrary
Clifford computation this is like a much
stronger statement yeah
yes yes
is it true with this implication still
hold if you have and see one over
quarterly not equal element reportedly
in fact it's that's exactly what I mean
so I I need the non-uniform version of
these classes
foreign
there is a uniform version of the same
that you can make but it's a little bit
Messier because then you need branded
this uh
okay and so I'm going to sort of try to
actually just go through and sort of
show you the main proof ideas for these
two uh results and then I'm sort of like
talk about
open problems that I sort of like hope
can be solved here
any question yeah yeah this is
uh I think kind of uh
the circuit is like you know you can
think of every circuit is going to be
sorry every gate in the in the Clifford
circuit is going to be controlled on one
of the input bits and that input is
either off or on and it determines
whether or not apply that
basically
Yeah well yeah I mean it's uh yeah the
input will always be possible
thank you it's uh the input of the
problem is a classical bit string that
fit string is given as the input to your
your circuit and in some ways yeah
exactly just like yeah like on the
second slide
so so let me go on here
um
but the control of ours are independent
of the rest of it so or they do depend
on yeah the control wires are
independent of the input the input the
input there's sort of two ways of
thinking about it one way is like you
just have a fixed classically controlled
circuit and then the inputs sort of just
go through the circuit and sort of they
turn on certain Gates and turn off
certain Gates and the other way of
thinking about it is like there's a very
sort of low depth way of sort of
generating the Clifford circuit from the
input
um
sorry but but um wasn't there it's like
being being generated through these uh
auxiliary inputs so it doesn't depend
upon the rest of them
right so right so I mean let me let me
just go back since this is a point
so we can start like we can start with a
fixed uh classically controlled Clipper
circuit like this and and like for every
end you know this is like a uniform
class will be some fixed circuit which
is there and then your input is going to
be
this right so this of your this is your
classical input and it's kind of like
you know if it's zero it's going to turn
off this gate if it's one it's going to
turn it on uh and then sort of like what
you can sort of think about you can sort
of think about it in two frames like two
phases like in the first phase you just
like see what your classical input is
giving you right so it's gonna
you know it's going to turn on some of
these Gates and turn off some of them
and then what you have remaining is just
the Clifford circuit yeah yeah so so
you're saying um
um your input determines the different
circuit and then you want to know what
it outputs on on input zero right
yeah yeah and in particular the quantum
circuit rate it's sampling from some
distribution right or whatever and then
the classical thing the only thing that
we acquire from the back of the is that
it gives us one element of the support
of that distribution right so the
classical the classical device is doing
something simpler than what the quantum
device is doing
foreign
Okay so
I want to talk a little bit about how
you get uh so these Quantum Advantage
results from uh non-locality so in
particular how do we prove the sort of
bgk result so the separation between q
and C 0 circuits and nc0 circuits
so uh we're talking about non-locality
so it makes uh sense to sort of start
with a non-local game so we're going to
start uh with the GHC game which I'm
sure many of you have seen if not all of
you but let me just sort of uh review it
in in any case so we have this
three-player game so uh a B and C are
these three players and they can't
communicate with each other and then
there's some referee which is going to
send each of them a bit
so a b and c so a goes to a b goes to b
c goes to C and you know C doesn't know
what bit B got
right so they all get their own bits
and they all have to return their own
bits uh x y and z
and then the referee is going to do some
check so that the referees are going to
check if the or of the inputs is equal
to the xor of the answers
and the referee will make it even easier
on the on the players and say look I
promise you that I'm only ever going to
give you questions where the parody of
the the questions is zero
and now you just have to you know let's
say the the the referee draws a question
which is uniform rendered to this
constraint and the question is sort of
like with what probability can these
players win this game
and many of you have seen that sort of
classically sort of like the best thing
you can do is win with probability three
over four so I'll show this but but
quantumly uh you can win with
probability one so okay what does it
even mean to have a Quantum strategy
what it means is that the players a b
and c get to start with some shared
entanglement so they start with this ghd
state so uh you know player a has one
qubit of the state player B has another
qubit of the state and player C has
another qubit of the state and they're
going to use this GHC State as sort of a
resource to win this game and if they
use this resource they can win with
probability one
this is some kind of like uh
separation that you can actually Witness
okay just because it's simple and nice
let me actually just go through these
proofs so how do you get this classical
lower bound so there's really only four
possible uh sets of questions that you
can ask because of the fact that that
parody has to be zero right so they can
all be zero which case the answer is
zero so I better output
you know the three players better output
X Y and Z such that the period of the
output is zero uh and then you know all
three of the cases where two of the
inputs are one
and so the first sort of observation uh
which we can make here is that if A and
B and C are randomized since the we've
already randomized the questions from
the referee
there's always some sort of uh convex
combination some convexity argument that
will uh allow us to just sort of assume
that A B and C are playing with a
deterministic strategy so now we can
just assume like what is the best
deterministic strategy that a b and c
can have given that they know that the
referee is drawing from this particular
distribution
so let's look at deterministic
strategies right so if a uh gets a bit
zero it's going to do something if a get
to bit one it's going to do something
and so this is just like a function we
can compute so what a does on zero what
a doesn't want what B doesn't zero what
C doesn't zero and so on and so forth so
we can write down all of the constraints
that we need to have
in order to solve this game right so we
need in this case right we need that the
xor of the answer is a zero in this case
we need to X where the answer there's
one and so on and so forth
I but you know you can uh sort of stare
at this and you see that if you sum up
all over the entries over here and sum
up all of the entries on the on the
right hand side well you know mod 2
right so these are all going to cancel
and so you get zero equals one and so
one of these constraints must not have
been satisfied so you know you sort of
failed one of these constraints so you
know let's just say I felt exactly one
of them then I can I can succeed at
three of them so my winning
probabilities at most three or before
and sort of uh quantumly uh here's the
quantum strategy so they I'm not really
going to go into into detail but you can
sort of like check to see that it works
so
each player is going to sort of run the
same algorithm so on input bit s if s
was Zero they're going to measure uh in
the X basis so they apply a hadamard and
measure if s was one they're going to
measure in the in the in the Y basis so
they'll apply a phase gate and then
apply ahead of Art and then measure and
then you just output whatever your
measurement result is and you can check
that if you sort of go if you go through
the computation starting from a ghd
state that you will always satisfy this
check
so so this is kind of nice right so we
we have this non-local game right but in
something we want to take the non-local
game and and say something about
circuits right so we want to sort of
come back to reality now and say
something about actual circuits so in
order to sort of the sort of language we
do use to sort of formalize this notion
is is a light cone so uh the light cone
of an input is just sort of the set of
outputs which are affected uh by that
input so for instance the light cone of
this input here if you can see it is
sort of like these three bits here
because these are the set of outputs
which are affected by that input
so now we can sort of phrase what the
GHC game is is sort of telling us in
terms of of light cones
so so the theorem that we showed before
is that the maximum winning probability
of the GHC game is three over four
so uh you know a theorem that you can
derive from that is that if I have sort
of a three input three output classical
circuit which is actually Computing this
gsu's relation so it's it's winning with
probability greater than three over four
then there must be two input bits whose
light cones sort of non-trivial
intercept
right because if the light cones didn't
intersect right that would mean that
there was essentially only one output
bit per input bit and you could think of
the circuit as sort of being an
instantiation of the game itself where
each one of the circuits outputs is like
one of the players of the game
and so since we know that in you know
from this theorem that you can't win the
DLC game with probability three or four
it must be the case that that did not
happen right the the likelins did
intersect
okay so so we we've gone from a
non-local game and we've said something
non-trivial
about sort of circuits which must
compute this game but okay this is still
uh this is still kind of unsatisfying
right because we have three inputs three
outputs like there's there's you know
there's still a constant size circuit
like clearly an nc0 circuit could solve
a problem like this and you know just
just have a somewhat large light cone
and not even large light cone like light
kind of size two or whatever and you can
solve this problem
so we need some way of like taking the
the GHC game and sort of like blowing it
up right so take it from like a three
qubit problem to an end qubit problem
so I claim that a natural way to sort of
generalize it is what I'm going to call
sort of the big GHC game so I'm going to
uh sort of stop referring to the
relation problem in terms of sort of the
sort of like abstract sort of relation
between bitstrings I'm just going to
tell you what the quantum circuit is
doing and then the goal will be for the
classical circuit to do whatever the
quantum circuit is doing
um so what what is the Quantum circuit
doing so it so you know each one of
these
uh uh these these vertices here you can
think of this like as a player in the
game
and the resource state that they're
going to start with is uh the graph
State corresponding to this triangle
right so what is the graph state so each
vertex uh you know associated with the
qubit
and then you apply a CZ gate between uh
qubits if they share an edge in this
graph right and it's not too hard to see
that this thing this you know such a
thing can be prepared in constant depth
if you're worried about that
and so uh now what is the what is the
sort of big GHC relation well now you so
your inputs are a measurement basis for
the corner so you're going to get like a
for a B for b c for C again
and then your output is is basically the
same thing that you did for the uh sort
of original GHC game so you're you'll
measure an X if the bit was zero and
you'll measure it in y if it was one and
this is just for the corners
and for all of the all of the qubits on
the edges you just measure them in the X
basis
so it might not be sort of uh super easy
to see uh from from this picture but
this is this is actually the sort of uh
on a right generalization of the GAC
game so if you remove all of these Edge
qubits
um then you can show that this GHz state
is uh locally equivalent to this sort of
triangle and so it's the exact same game
okay
so I claim that we're sort of like
almost uh almost done here
so so so why are we almost done so what
is the relation problem
all right so we've said sorry and let me
let me step back so we Define this big
relation problem now we need to say the
same kind of statement uh about light
cones and
I I'm not going to go through the the
math this time but I I claim it's as
just essentially the same argument that
I made for the ghg game just slightly
more complicated
um so this was like first node noted by
buried at all and then sort of
repurposed by Ravi Gus and kunig
um and and so one way to phrase this
sort of big GHC game uh in terms of the
Litecoin argument is that every sort of
three input and output classical circuit
Computing this big ghg relation must
have an input bit whose light cone
contains an output at distance at least
D over two where D is sort of like the
minimum side length in this triangle
so this is saying something non-trivial
about
the the light cones in a circuit that
must compute this game right so you must
have your light cone sort of musco must
go far places it must go all the way
sort of like at least halfway towards
the output bit
so so now we sort of have this nice sort
of uh you know condition on on circuits
so now how do we how do we take this and
convert it into a a separation now
so let me sort of tell you what the the
problem is first and then we'll sort of
see how to embed that problem into this
problem so what is the bravic acid
configuration problem so you start with
the edges
of uh a 2d grid graph like this and your
input is going to specify so this is
once again this is a graph state so you
you know apply a a CZ gate on every Edge
and so the input is going to specify a
subset of the edges of the 2D grid graph
and also the input is going to set up
is going to set a set of uh measurement
bases for each one of the qubits
so the intuition here is that if I just
you know take one of the subset of the
edges to be one that corresponds to the
big triangle game then there's like a
big triangle game instance which is like
a sub instance of this problem
okay but the the the reason that we want
to work in the grid is there are tons
and tons of big triangle game instances
in this in this graph right right you
know I I picked three sort of vertices
for my big triangle instance right but
if I you know if I could pick up I could
have picked this one this one and this
one as well and that would have defined
a new instance
and and the sort of property that we saw
before is that there had to be this sort
of light cone relationship between the
input bits and the output bits in the
circuit and I claim that there are just
way too many big triangles in the grid
to possibly satisfy all of those
constraints
and it's just some big sort of uh
counting argument that gets you there
uh something like a probabilistic style
analysis okay so there's one thing that
you have to worry about why this
counting argument might not work which
is what if your light cones are actually
big right like I you know I haven't said
anything about the structure of my
circuit yet so so how can I guarantee
that all my light cones aren't this huge
right and that you know there's just
some circuit that does actually solve
this thing
so before we were looking at the four
light cones so the the set of outputs
that were affected by a particular input
right but you could also take a circuit
and think about it sort of backwards
like cone so the set of inputs that are
affected by that affect a particular
output so sort of you know if I fix an
output here and I look at all of the
input bits that affect it that would be
its backwards light cone and it's not
too hard to see that if there's an input
bit which is in the
uh backwards out uh light cone of a
particular output bit then that output
bit is going to be in the light cone of
that input bit as well
so this is going to be a a fact that
we're about to use but now uh if we
think about backward light cones there's
sort of a key fact that we can use for
nc0 circuits right because they're
bounded fan in the size of my backward
light cone is bounded right it's
exponential in the depth right because
at most each time I'm sort of like
multiplying by two here right but my
depth is constant because I've specified
this as a constant depth circuit
so the the backwards light comes in my
nc0 circuit are tiny right they're
they're constant size
and so I can create this graph so I have
my input bits and my output bits and by
this observation before like I'm going
to create an edge between the input bit
and output bit if the output bit is in
the light cone of the input bit or vice
versa right it's the same it's the same
question
but because of this property this
Litecoin argument that the degree we
have we we know that sort of the degree
of every output bit is at most constant
right which means that altogether this
graph is very sparse so there aren't
very many input bits which have high
degree which means for most input bits
they have very tiny light cones as well
and combining that observation with this
sort of probabilistic argument that I
was talking about before sort of
completes the proof
okay
maybe that was a lot
so I want to talk a little bit about
sort of how you go from these nc0
circuit separations to ac0 separations
so this is just follow Brooklyn Shaker
and tall
and sort of the sort of key Insight I
mean it's sort of weird to call it an
Insight because it's kind of obvious but
in any case sort of the output bits of
this bgk relationship basically what's
going on is you you need to satisfy a
bunch of parity constraints
and we we have very good techniques for
dealing with ac0 circuits that are
trying to compute things that look like
parity
right so if you if you've seen this
before uh this will be totally not
surprising to you but suppose you had an
ac0 circuit which solves the the bgk uh
relation
then I claim that it can be converted
into an nc0 circuit this thing called
that multi-switching Lemma and what is
what is the what is what is the ID here
the idea is like you're going to take
your circuit and you're just going to
sort of like randomly set some of the
inputs to zeros and ones
and what you can show is that you really
haven't like simplified your problem at
all for you like you you know you you
still have a very hard problem to solve
on the remaining bits but what you have
done is you sort of like killed off all
the big gates in your circuit right
because imagine I had some like
extremely large and gate in my circuit
and you know with some reasonable
probability if I'm just you know
randomly setting bits to zeros and one
with some reasonable probability I set
an input of that and gate to zero and
when I set an input the and gate to zero
it's just going to kill that gate off so
it sort of like doesn't exist and you
can think of it doesn't exist in the
circuit now
and so now I've taken my ac0 circuit and
sort of that was solving this bgk
relationship and now I just have an NC
serial circuit which solves the bgk
relationship
but we just proved that nc0 circuits
can't solve it
and so that's that's how you get the
result okay I mean like this is a you
know like a 60 page paper there's a lot
going on here that I'm simplifying but
uh that's sort of the main idea
can you say a little bit more about
how many bits do you have to to force to
close that or I think it's like
a square root of log or something like
this I think that's three small portions
yeah very very
I mean do you have a difficulty with you
know showing that you can still embed
the hard problem into the remaining
unfixed bits uh
no but it has it has a little bit to do
with sort of like the way that they set
up the problem they set up their
problems a bit differently so that it's
it's not sort of phrased in the way that
I did the way that they phrase it it
when they phrase it and then they they
they require a decent amount of
expedition to get there but they the way
that they phrase the problem it really
is just like a problem about parries
um so you're given
uh you're given a a particular uh
it's which you're given a string which
is either zero or two mod four and
you're asked asked to Output uh a bit
string of parity zero if you got
something with zero and this string a
pair you want if you got something of
two mod four and so when we can when you
so think about things in in this way
it's sort of more obvious but is your
problem still spatially local like on a
2d grid
yeah
so yeah the nc0 pro right so the the
quantum circuit is basically local but
the classical circuit is not okay I mean
on your earlier slide it looked like the
key was that you could embed all these
different triangles and to your grid so
like do you have my question was do you
have to check that that is still true
after random restriction
uh
you you might have to do if you if you
solved it in this way but they don't
solve it
yeah all right but yeah it's a good
question all right but I I I think even
if you did try to do that I think that
would still be fine because you're
setting so few in the bits okay fine
okay
in relation to make this happen like how
General is this
well the the bgk relation is just some
relation problem which we know cannot be
solved by an anti-zero circuit and so
we're just kind of reducing down to it
right what other relations
uh I mean I I I think it would hope for
like any most random Clipper circuits uh
on uh you know that have reasonable
connectivity
um I didn't you might have to spend some
work to to prove that but yeah I think
it should be pretty General
I'll talk a little bit maybe about some
of that
okay
good question any more questions about
it I'm about to sort of move on so if
you have questions about this
okay so so now I want to sort of move
away from this sort of like a
non-locality picture and
sort of interactivity
um and I I don't have near as much time
to sort of go into details here but
hopefully I'll give you some some sort
of like a brief sketch of how this goes
um so first of all you know what is this
interactive relation task that it keeps
sort of alluding to right so once again
we start with some sort of like fixed uh
constant depth Clifford circuit and
there's going to be two rounds so in the
first round you're going to specify some
single cubic Gates just like we did
before these these single cubic gates
are the basis measurements that you're
making right and so then sort of the
task for the the quantum device is just
sort of like you know apply those Gates
and measure in the appropriate basis
and then it returns in the first round
sort of the measurement outcomes that it
got as an answer to that problem
uh you know consistent with whatever the
Clifford circuit is doing
and in the second round you just do the
same thing but for the remaining gate so
you specify some bases for the remaining
qubits uh the quantum circuit should
just you know apply those those Gates
and those those bases you know measure
and sort of return uh the measurement
outcomes
and uh once again you can sort of think
of what's going on here as you're just
starting with a a graph state so you
know we've applied all we started with
the
um all the all of the vertices in this
plus State and we apply these CZ Gates
between them
and you're just sort of measuring the
graph state in appropriate basis X or Y
depending on what input you're given in
this problem
and so the sort of the task for the the
classical circuit is to sort of do sort
of report any transcript that the
classical circuit or that the quantum
circuit could have
responded with
so this is this is the problem
so so so why should we why why why does
it make sense to switch to these
interactive tasks like this why is this
a useful primitive so let's let's like
think about the what this interactive
task looks like from the perspective of
the classical device now in fact like I
I've written this as like a you know
ac02 circuit but like really this will
hold for like any classical simulator
that you would have for this task
so think about so you know after you
sort of ask your first round questions
this classical simulator
there's some you know classical state
that it has which is sort of holding
what has happened after this first round
of computation is done
right so that means that sort of is and
this is sort of a key idea so that means
that when you sort of ask it to these
questions in the second round
you can then sort of like if you want
you can sort of go back and sort of
rewind the classical simulator to ask it
a different question
then you originally did in the second
round conditioned on its first round in
answers
right so I can ask like several
different questions in the second round
which were conditioned on the answers
that it gave in the first round so this
is a power that we don't really have
quantumly right quantumly if I if I give
you an answer here and then I measure
and I give you an answer here then like
the best thing I can do is just sort of
start all the way over right but there's
no guarantee that I get measurement
outcomes which were the same ones that I
got before in which case like when if I
ask a different question I may be just
asking some totally unrelated thing
and so there's a sense in which a
classical Simulator for these
interactive tasks is actually much much
more powerful than the quantum
stimulator itself and we're gonna and
we're going to sort of Leverage that
fact to sort of prove these sort of like
kind of surprising uh separations
um so here is the sort of formal theorem
uh yeah I think I can say it so suppose
there's a classical simulator which is
solving this sort of two round
measurement problem on grids of with M
so I I I mentioned in the beginning that
you can sort of always think of this as
sort of like measuring uh sort of a grid
graph state
and sort of if m equals n so basically
you have like a square grid as
as you're starting a problem
then you can sort of take your classical
simulator R and sort of Leverage it to
solve a parity L hard problem and
remember these parallel hard problems
were the hardest problems in Clifford's
okay so uh you know sort of more
technically you can with an ac0 circuit
with access to this classical simulator
you can solve essentially any Clifford
problem that you want to solve
and remember that this clip this just
simulating a constant depth circuit
right so this classical simulator
simulating what a constant depth circuit
is doing and yet somehow through this
power of rewinding we're seeing that it
can be leveraged to solve Clifford
computation of any depth
okay so there's some sort of few
auxiliary results here so if you if you
have like squatter grids you can sort of
Leverage it to to solve weaker and
weaker problems but okay maybe for
whatever reason you want to start with a
squat grid
um so I'm just gonna I I think I've said
this enough time but let me just sort of
throw this out again as another warning
right so this theorem is not saying that
constant depth Clifford circuits solve
paradiel hard problems it's saying that
if you had
a classical Simulator for these constant
depth good for circuits that worked in
this interactive model then you could
leverage that simulator to solve this
paradial heart problem
so okay let's just say it look sort of
like very briefly how you take this and
leverage it to prove a sort of
separation
so
let's we I want to show that there's no
sort of ac02 circuit which will solve
the sort of two round measurement
problem
uh so Suppose there was right so Suppose
there was an ac02 circuit to solve this
two-round measurement problem well then
just sort of like looking at the sort of
uh second uh line in this in this
theorem we can sort of instantiate r
with our ac02 circuit so we have NC nc1
is contained in ac0 with an oracle
access to ac02 all right okay but now
this ac0 is not doing anything ac02
Oracle is doing all the hard work so
this is just equal to ac02 but we know
that ac02 does not contain nc1 this is
by the way as both monsie theorem
so we can't have such a separation or we
can't have such an inclusion
what's special about ac06 or is it any
it is something special about a206 yes
this is that's as tight as it can be so
this is these are these are all all of
the sort of models of computation that
you get from measurement based Quantum
computation on that particular thing so
Clifford measurement based computation
on a line gives you the power of ac06.
yeah so I've been this whole time I've
been putting a 2 in the bracket which
means Perry here that you actually need
the six so the six instead of parity
it's mod six so you have mod six eights
instead of
it
okay so let me just give you a very uh
sort of uh caricature of how to prove
this result
all right so let me sort of like switch
back to the perspective of the quantum
circuit again so prefer we've got the
interactive protocol from distracted the
classical circuit now let's think about
it in terms of the perspective of the
quantum circuit so in the first round
I'm going to give you some some bases
and you're going to take those uh you're
gonna measure in those bases and return
the results
and then what we can show is there's
some leftover Quantum estate on the
remaining wires
and what we can show is that through
measurement-based Quantum computation I
mean this is not super hard to see that
you know what we're doing is we're
making poly measurements on a grid so
you know what what's left over if we're
if we're doing something right should be
you know a state which is like kind of
an arbitrary Clifford computation okay
there's a there's a lot of complication
here actually because there's a a hidden
poly that you can't uh correct but let
me I'm just going to totally brush over
that right now and say that you just
have a state here which you sort of
through measurement based computation
have uh prepared some state
which is you know uh if we're doing
measurement based computation we're
doing some we're affecting some
arbitrary clever computation so there's
some state which encodes a hard problem
here like a parodyl hard problem
and what we can show is that now that we
have the state with this sort of
rewinding ability we can make many
measurements of this state right so we
can make some measurement we can take a
different basis we can measure in that
basis and so on and so forth we make a
bunch of different measurements of the
state and then we can collect all those
measurement statistics together and
through a result uh this is we're
actually going to use uh the magic
square game here and I'm just going to
sort of label it on the umbrella of
quantum contextuality if you make a
bunch of measurements of the state you
can actually determine what it is
um this seems like a really simple
statement based on how I presented the
the slide like you just whatever you
just have state there make a bunch of
measurements of it this is actually very
non-trivial but I there's a lot of
complication that I'm not going to go
into but
um in any case if you combine these two
things together you sort of see
how you can sort of Leverage uh uh weak
classical simulator to to solve a hard
problem if you have this permanent right
so if I had some weak classical
simulator then I sort of simulate what
the device is doing in the first round
and then I had this thing in the second
round that I can make multiple
measurements to and if I can make
multiple measures to it I can figure out
what it is if I can figure out what it
is I can solve a hard problem
to measurement based Quantum computation
so that's like a very high level
uh how it goes and there's lots of
Tricks yeah
the classical
as powerful as a post-selected uh
um
yeah
in this case right this is specific to
Clippers
I think so post q and c0 is all right be
careful
I've been I
I saw you know that's the most natural
Quantum class but most people say q and
c0 they mean arbitration or our
arbitration would be the gates
here I really mean quicker games
right so I mean we know we know we know
that post qnc zero if I like turtle or
whatever like that that's you know it's
Universal you know the sort of Gate
transportation stuff so you can't post
select that would be bad
or are you or if you could you used to
get some kind of trivial results right
it's a trivia hard to do
okay
so this is sort of the the complete uh
outline so let me just say a little bit
about sort of open uh questions and so
like other directions I think are
interesting to sort of pursue here so
sort of we sort of like started the the
whole talk was like we had this you know
we had this diagram of
uh circuit classes and we sort of asked
you know where do these shallow circuits
go on you saw a Clifford circus Beyond
and and what we sort of found was that
it's it's kind of non-trivial right like
there's a sense in which it it is as
powerful as Clifford itself but that's
only whenever you know you sort of have
this sort of like interactive sampler
and it's like if you have a classical
sampler for the quantum device like this
is very sort of non-trivial statement so
it's not exactly clear uh where it fits
but there's some sense in which it's as
powerful as it could be right so the
power sort of is going to max out at
parity L and in some sense it does
there's a classical Simulator for it
so sort of the the thing that I sort of
hope hopefully is sort of like driven
home to you right is like you know this
is interactive versus non-interactive
question here so you know a sort of
natural question is what's the best
quantity Advantage result you can get
with that interaction and you know one
of the the reasons that I sort of like
this question in this sort of like low
depth query world is it sort of mirrors
the same discussion that we're like sort
of currently having in this sort of RCS
world right in the quantum Supremacy
world right do we need these sort of
like proofs of interactive proofs of
quantum this
um to actually sort of exhibit a Quant
advantage and this is sort of like one
way you can phrase it as well it's like
this is kind of like a playground for
that discussion like what is the right
answer so right now interaction is
winning in the in the Clifford picture
right we can we can say a lot more about
um the hardness of classical simulators
in the interactive picture than we can
in the non-interactive picture
but this is sort of you know not
necessarily the case I mean we just use
interactivity in this case to get
rewinding so this is like a kind of
trick that we used so that we could sort
of bootstrap the power of the classical
simulator do something more
right but you could you could hope for
you know different sorts of things
different kind of ideas that that might
help you I mean one thing that you could
really you know get your hopes out what
if you just had like a black box
reduction like what if I could just like
have some ac0 circuit which you know has
access to the outputs of a qnc zero
circuit and then leverage that to solve
a hard problem okay we don't think that
this is true so I'm gonna I'm gonna put
it as a conjecture that like if you have
an ac0 circuit with an oracle access to
q and zero circuit then it can't
actually compute things in nc1
okay I actually have a who can actually
have a stronger version of this
conjecture if you really care which is
that qnz0 with fan out cannot even
compute nc1 but okay if you don't know
what that is that's okay but in any case
we think that these sort of Black Box
reductions are not going to work
and so we're going to need
to we're going to need a new idea
essentially to move from inner the
interactive setting to the
non-interactive setting we need
something you know in with the RCs and
these uh the sampling based Supremacy we
have this idea of if you have a Quantum
uh device which is sampling from some
distribution then the thing that you use
is you use the fact that a classical
device you can sort of pull out the
randomness and use stockmar counting on
that so you know that's one trick here
this interactivity isn't a trick like
what more tricks uh can we come up with
so I think this is like a very very hard
question
but I do have a belief and the belief is
that it should be possible to prove a
separation between q and c0 using these
like Clifford circuits and ac03 so like
ac0 with the mod 3 Gates
and this is just using a a relation
problem so now we can I I believe that
you should be able to prove this and
like you know maybe within our graph in
terms of technical capabilities and why
do I believe this
so we started with sort of like
non-locality which we we know that's a
trick that we have in classical
complexity and then we went and we used
the switching Lemma in in a very
non-trivial way with this this Benny
Watts guitar chafer and Tall paper
but we haven't really used Roswell
malinski yet in a non-trivial way
for these circuit simulation so is there
some way to use raspolacemanski in a
non-trivial way to prove a separation
between q and zero and a to zero sorry
yeah I mean I'd actually be it this is
actually still very non-trivial even
even if you move away from Clifford
um
uh debts would be fine as long as you're
not
uh being uh maybe I unless you're doing
something very tricky with your create
there
um
so let me let me let me show you one
result which is uh almost here actually
or depending on your definition of
almost so in in the paper Benny wants to
Starship result they also show uh
something which almost gets there so
they share a relation separation between
q and c0 and ac02
but
your qnc zero circuit also has access to
a cat state so it it has as a resource
when it starts the computation like a
perfect super equal superposition
between zeros and ones
and it's not too hard to see that if you
have access to a state like this you can
start doing things that look like mod 3
computations where if you if you want to
do a mod 3 computation you imagine sort
of rotating this phase by like pi over
three or two pi over three or whatever
and you rotate it three times you get
back to itself right so if you do that
in each one of these bits and you've got
some kind of way of con of sort of
reasoning about uh mod 3 computation and
you can sort of formalize this to show
the separation between ac02 because now
you have something that's doing
something mod 3 but you know mod 2
circuits shouldn't really be able to do
that
okay uh let me just uh very very briefly
uh mention some other things so here's
another problem that I care a lot about
so I've like basically this whole time
I've been talking about Quantum
advantage in terms of depth with these
these constant depth Clipper circuits
but you know
are there other things and you know
other you know quantities are there
properties of the circuit that also
might serve as a basis for Quantum
Advantage so one one that we thought
that you know might exist is that
uh
the not only you know do you have this
advantage in your depth but the circuit
is extremely simple right there's like
you know end many gates if n is the sort
of uh size of your your circuit
the
what what if you like what if there was
an advantage like in terms of time like
the number of discrete Ops uh discrete
operations that you needed
uh classically even if you sort of did
away with the sort of uh
uh depth constraint like what if that
was like extremely high so there's some
there would there be some sense in which
you have a Quantum Quantum advantage in
terms of sort of like this just kind of
the number of operations that you're
running
there's some sense uh which I show with
uh Gossip Coastline Schaefer that this
is kind of not true we show that there's
like ridiculously fast classical
algorithms for these these problems
right so there's these n to the Omega
over two uh so Omega here is the matrix
multiplication
um constant uh for stimulating these
constant depth circuits on this 2D grid
right so like in the extreme case right
what if Omega is equal to two we don't
know maybe it is right then you get sort
of like linear time classical algorithms
or sampling these things so this is like
ridiculously fast things and these
things these are actually practical as
well I mean okay not not if you if you
implement the matrix multiplication but
if you substitute three here instead you
you get very fast algorithms uh and in
fact this sort of extends to all sort of
these graph State sampling problems uh
where you sort of start with a
a a graph state that has low tree width
if you know what that is
um and so you know maybe maybe one
question here is well can you get the
same kind of quantum Advantage result
but instead of using one of these 2D
grid graphs maybe you use like an expand
your graph instead so it would at least
sort of like rule out the sort of low
tree width kind of simulation
um it turns out uh by this results of
how's it going like all that yes you can
actually do this but they can only show
it for nz0 so we actually don't know how
to extend this sort of interactive
result to the case where you you start
with an expenditure graph so maybe like
sort of generally speaking like is there
is there a characterization of graph
States for which you can do measurement
based Quantum computation uh this is the
problem I've been working on with Kunal
that seems like uh maybe uh it has some
use here
yeah I mean yeah I mean
it would be kind of a
the result that you would get would just
would just be that our best classical
algorithms run in time which is like N
squared instead of n
um and so
maybe that's interesting maybe it's not
I mean we probably couldn't actually
prove that that's the right lower bound
we could just say like we tried really
hard and that's the best algorithm we
came up with but it still might be sort
of mildly interesting
um yeah so anyways that's a question and
let me just wrap up I I just want to say
that there's like a bunch of other
things I didn't get to both in terms of
the talk and also preparing the slide
um so there's like you know these you
can make these circuits noise robust you
can show that there's average case
hardness uh you can even show some kind
of sense in which there you still get a
quantum Advantage even if you like don't
even have an input uh that's determining
what you're searching so anything I just
want to sort of like flag those results
in case you want to ask me about them
later but that's all thanks
[Applause]
yeah
from my point of view description so
very much like coherent States and that
is it feels that that maybe you could
have similar results for for all
different coherences like ocean States
FIFA meal States is
actually yeah I've thought about it idly
and probably like the same amount of
depth that you just thought about it
like it seems like something like that
should maybe be true but I haven't
explored it's a good question
again I probably missed this uh very
basic point but you basically say that
the inter adding interaction increases
the the Gap to separation can you say it
again why
in more sense well I mean we don't know
why I guess but uh
yeah I mean the same thing exactly okay
I mean here's the best unconditional
separation we can prove without
interaction we can prove that there's a
task which is solved by a constant
flipping circuit whatever the shallow
paper targets that can't be solved by an
ac0 circuit
with interaction we can show that it
can't be solved by a zero circuit with
parity Gates
so it's like a strictly a strictly
bigger class of classical circuit for
which we know how to prove a quantum
is that is
you can even do more yeah so we can do
more but the problem is the the
classical complexity there is need to
get on it right like we we like what we
can show is that if you know if you had
a classical Simulator for these tasks
you could leverage it to solve parody
out complete problems
when does that prove a separation only
when paradiel is different from some
class below it
foreign
there could be a you know yeah it's
any any constant I will give you nc1
um other than one other than the Y which
gives you this ac0 like you could you
could uh you could you could ask for
like what if yeah I have like a a log n
by n circuit or something like this
um in that case what you could do is you
could use it to solve uh like branching
programs of like login with it's I I
don't know of a clean characterization
of that of that class in terms of these
circuit classes but it's it's
um that's the kind of result that you
would get
yeah so you mentioned that when you add
the Gap State you can do sort of more
three but yeah in this location yes
it can be expanded to uh mod Prime
right because that's that's the only way
in which we like the razor boss Monsey
exam is kind of annoying right it it the
mouse so okay what is the restaurant
theorem say it says that ac0p circuits
are not the same as ac0q circuits for
any p and Q which are different Primes
now you might think you know one thing
that you might conjecture is that if p
and Q are co-prime that's not no
yeah
Clifford circuits with rewinding you can
post select
you can like simulate post like click
with circuits
imagine this is because you can like
kind of just do teleportation
yeah something like that should work
though I mean you have to be very very
careful about your model
of simulation so in our we pick what we
think is like essentially the weakest
model of simulation that you can have in
terms of like
both having interactively and having a
relation problem like those relations
relational outputs can be chosen
adversarially in our model and it's a
ton of work to get around that
if you if you had a sampler right if I
could just sample a bunch of times all
of these results would actually become
much more easy to prove
um there's actually a
uh that's probably a bad idea okay
it turns out it's not it's not it's not
completely obvious but it's not too hard
to show that for the relational problems
for the kinds of uh these sort of uh
sort of 2D grid bgk relationship you're
talking about for the relation problem
and the sampling problem are the same
right like it's raised in terms of
relation problems because it's uh it's
somewhat nicer in some sense right it
seems like you're giving the uh you
seems like you're given the classical
device in slack like it's it's you can
use easier task but actually you can
show that if you can solve the relation
problem you can actually just you can
actually sample we do not know that this
is true in the interactive setting and
in fact I suspect that it's false right
so if you solve this sort of like
interactive relation problem you do not
solve the interactive
yeah okay so in any case we don't think
it's possible to improve this relation
to anything larger than parity L and
it's impossible for the first circuits
yeah so I mean certainly if you go
beyond Clifford circuits I mean we think
we think
we think there's some evidence of
responsibility
for Clifford circuits we can prove that
it maxes out of area
yeah there's you know you might you
might worry that this sort of uh this
inclusion here was originally only
proven for sort of like decision
problems that we had like a single
output so we like went back and we like
reproved this whole result for like
relationship
we wanted to make this harder like could
you just make it like an interactive
sampling task
you could uh there there's some sense in
which that
makes I mean there's there's some weird
things where you like you have to be
careful about
uh what you what you what you ask of the
the classical life you can have one of
these interactive class but then
it feels like in some sense you're
you're cheating the the classical device
in some sense because you're you're
saying that like the classical device
must have some kind of when it's solving
this interactive problem unless the
randomness that it's using in step one
has to be sort of independent of the
randomness that's using in step two
where in reality like the sort of most
General notion of simulation you could
think of like if it's using some random
bits in step one maybe you want to use
those same random bits and step two to
solve an answer and in that case there's
a correlation between the two things
that you can't get rid of and that's why
you need this sort of relation thing
instead of assembly
yeah so when you mentioned it to end
that there are results with no input
yeah I mean now we can say more about
this uh basically it's a okay let me let
me uh let me just sort of tell you what
the problem what does that even mean
right uh so what is it what does that
even mean it means that
so so here you have an input X which is
a big screen which is determining what
your circuit is and then you you know
then you're just a sampling from your
distribution instead you can think of
input is
not input is just n right my input is
just like how many uh qubits am I acting
on and then there's some fixed circuit
and then how hard is it assemble from
that thing
and the results that you get there are
are much much weaker than what we did
here but you can get something
so you get to you still get the
separation yeah now what's the what's
the what's the what's the exact result
so I don't mess it up
um yeah they're just like a family of
quantum circuits like this
um
foreign
and then as input it gets like uniformly
random bits but it has to have like a
limited number of uniformly random bits
so like Phantom plus n to the delta
um then you need log log depth
classically
to sample like even a little bit better
than just if you did random trying to
approximate the distribution of the
Quantum Services
[Applause]